usp
benvenuti simi tornati simi al bayern lo
berdych
no quello no vabbè è da un pò appunto
che lo facciamo da quando abbiamo visto
da fare anche cose un po su è un tocco
di merda ma riproviamoci ragazzi allora
partiamo da honda o mike tyson meno male
che non è mai record che sanno dovevo fa
scrivevo facchinetti mike tyson è il più
famoso della honda no no la honda è
sempre famoso di mike tyson ma molto più
famoso di recife card è bravissimo si
regala una cella di più
nessuno se lo caga il cancello ai vecchi
cassonetti ci fai qua c'è nessuna chiusa
due oscar che si imbarazza e vero mi
ricordo quando milano le verifiche due è
di schiena la stessa che gode uguale
play again con un xfactor 74.000
l'azione capire su misfatto
risultati e gli esami meno fatti perché
i risultati degli esami di chi gmail
52 milioni sparo
ok più o meno è ha sparato alto pensa ai
knicks non so cosa sia il pidocchio
essere un romeno palla out 4 almeno
almeno 3 milioni uno solo per farla wto
non sono però va bene omofobia meno
secondo non lo so nemmeno i fall out
cioè omofobia e sessismo minchia
incredibile omofobia s sisma cioè baltic
ice capito in quale le due cose e
cercate di più se come la sull'uomo
fobìe non lo so omofobia
no se si muove li
[Musica]
abbiamo fatti 5 per ci stiamo scaldando
laicità non scaldare importante
scaldarsi vesco brada o abba
prada
bene ma andata benissimo tra l'altro
incredibile lui e belen e reti più belle
l'uomo che abbiamo visto i soliti
sospetti mi chiamano ok sono i soliti
sospetti un insolito spesso io chef gesù
dai gesuiti seguo da quando insomma sei
risorto quindi penso che i ragazzi mi fa
troppo ridere il paragone gesù e de
parfum bellissimo io farei che ne so
penso lo so
gesù
grande gesù catley generano nei tagli
sia penso sia una famiglia jenner tipo
car kylie del promesso
quindi lei perfetto che influenza lo
schiaccio di bruno mars bruno mars ha
almeno due milioni 3 milioni per
l'anomala 1 marzo
24 24 ancora vederlo tra l'altro come lo
vedrò meno comunque
porca put corsi cliccato 24 è questo e
perché non l'ho visto quindi cazzi miei
nella meglio me lo merito next parigi o
il super bowl super bowl stessa cosa
uguale a incredibile su per voi o
wikipedia wikipedia credo che abbia
se gmail a 500 milioni wiki pd avrà 86
milioni no
se
solo mi chiama detto molto di più
zinedine zidane dai realizzi da andai mi
sembrano così di star trek di più dai
tre chili più soprattutto per la serietà
pacioso netflix o ha il grandissimo ben
altri e non conosco mi spiace però è
meno 880 blade runner di più è la maggio
quanta gente clicca blade runner il
padrino non può allora il padrino non
può essere meno cliccato di vedran del
cementifico impossibile però blade
runner era uscito il sequel attenzione
quindi era cliccato perché la stava
uscendo sicure forse era già uscito
quindi meno
madonna ma quanto in quanto in quanto
quanto era giusto ragionamento
incredibile all'ill.mo meno anche l'asia
schuetz
ma cosa ma cosa come di meno la cioè
bolkan osservino paragliding paragliding
pareva linea de curtis paragliding a dan
curtis e più ripano ai soldi dai dai
siamo ci siamo mamma mia non sono più
pagato nessuno che cocker spaniel
molto di più della sorte incredibile
paul pogba
come cocker spaniel infatti non sappiamo
se mettere in attacco lui la juve o un
cocker spaniel antas sicuramente di più
di paul pogba grande canta michia kurt
angle kurt angle da ponte che non lo
sentivo da quando ho 18 anni
ak 47
va bene però la storica 70 ma emersa in
spencer i grandissimi marks and spencer
sono due grandissimi marchi aspetto 2
face lift meno va bene ogni tanto mi
viene l'occhio che ci sono soprattutto
quando sono stanco e mi penso sempre di
fare questa cosa metta con lo scotch
ladro a don sergio gasparin al 5 milioni
500 mila e 500 e labrador avere almeno
un milione migliore 2 porca vacca
labrador e britains got al è però
labrador 13 12 record di oggi jim brown
che sembrano meno
ricordi oggi ragazzi shutter island ha
di più mica di caprio perfetto 14 ed è
record seaworld meno
uguale va bene va bene va bene va bene
uguale black eyed peas di più
no no i black eyed peas non si ricordano
più cacchio larga 14 gran record però
anzi 15 album non ci possiamo lamentare
cioè record assoluto era 30 e passa ma
l'abbia mandata una volta e nella vita
quindi va beh non ci possiamo lamentare
la cava benissimo
va bene ragala facciamo ancora un paio
perché per ora mi sono sentito molto
forte in realtà proviamo ancora un paio
suo live in meno forse a dormono da
quando c'è a lande volato ci credi
welder vuol dire che sia meno va bene
era di più ottimo clarinetto on wateraid
clarinetto wateraid of rage bulldogs
france bull dog e fino a qua kristen
stewart kristen stewart che ha fatto di
recente
oddio disattivo va bene incredibile tra
l'altro dotto altre meno dottor 3 dai
leaks estivo madonna qualcosa fatto che
se si fa così tanto le cure e techint o
di più
ok anche questa è buona è
di rame 10 sai che non lo so meno
nicchia rischiato qua è perché era un po
jennifer lawrence allora e kristen
verterà 2000 nei due cd parole sarà
tre migliori
e più o meno senegal senegal meno
4 50 ma che stai lì ma che cycling ma
che cycling xfactor di più dai
c'è ancora considerazione dei talent
come sono stato tra cliccati invece sono
prova bello hans e scelsi al csm in un
milione porca [ __ ] loro lower yao
ming grande yao ming che schiacciano se
niente fosse a one o superbad
so cosa sia
perfetto spero che il video vi sia
piaciuto signore sia io vi adoro e so
che comunque diverse reti di scaricarlo
per io no però comunque e diverte da
grande cioè da un certo modo e
divertente speriamo di migliorare ma
anche perché ci hanno fatto quello del
telefono le prossime lo faccio per il
telefono perché almeno un po diversi
sono comunque immagini diverse
cambiamo un po però che lui sia piaciuto
ragazzi cosa è giunto il momento mi
piace scusate mi stavo poca voce oggi ma
la sto recuperando pian piano se si
siede era come sempre ci vediamo al
prossimo vito era ragazzi
[Musica]